el nombre brión a taylor fue creado por
cientos de personas que exigen justicia
en su caso la manifestación se llevó a
cabo de forma pacífica no obstante dos
personas fueron detenidas
[Música]
la familia de taylor reclamó a la
fiscalía que publique las evidencias
presentadas ante el jurado luego de que
el miércoles determinara que los agentes
actuaron de forma justificada
el fiscal presentó alguna prueba en
nombre de brión a taylor o tomó una
decisión unilateral de poner su pulgar
en la balanza de la justicia para ayudar
a exonerar y justificar el asesinato de
brión a taylor por parte de estos
agentes de policía y al hacerlo
asegurarse de que la familia de brión a
taylor nunca tuviera su día en la corte
nunca tuviera la oportunidad de un
proceso debido y en esencia les negó la
justicia
sólo uno de los tres agentes implicados
en el caso fue imputado por imprudencia
temeraria mientras que los otros dos
fueron exonerados la familia recibirá
una indemnización de 12 millones de
dólares de parte del ayuntamiento de la
ciudad pero asegura que el dinero no
traerá de vuelta a brión
no sólo el fiscal le falló la falta de
investigación le falló el oficial que
dijo mentiras para obtener la orden de
redadas también le falló el juez que
firmó la orden le falló los terroristas
que irrumpieron en su casa le fallaron
el sistema entero le falló
taylor de 26 años era operar ya de
emergencias médicas y murió tras recibir
6 disparos de agentes que irrumpieron en
su vivienda en louisville en medio de
una supuesta redada antidrogas cuando
ella estaba descansando